[Musica]
[Applauso]
il mondo in cui vivo il grigio la nostra
strana bellezza la mattina nel foschie o
mondo grigio perla grigio del cemento
quando crolla di polvere di cemento
il mio un deserto di macerie cammini ad
aleppo per chilometri e chilometri
cammini sulla serie non c'è più niente
cammini come su una spiaggia di ghiaia
la spiaggia di ghiaia dopo una
mareggiata perché non sono solo cose di
cemento il vetro di faro le mie ma serie
sono piedi braccia mani test e ancora
riguardano ogni tanto il giornale
pubblica una foto di guerra ricomincia e
cominciò il dibattito ha senso mostra il
sangue i cadaveri o forse forse ottieni
l'opposto forse il lettore invece che
leggere si ritrae quelli su cui
discutete non sono neppure morti veri i
morti veri e non entra in una foto in
una inquadratura non sono tutti d un
pezzo sono i morti che la sera ti
ritrovi addosso che ti spazio l'idea dei
vestiti insieme al fango non avete mai
visto niente della guerra per questo
credete che possa esserci una guerra
giusta nella guerra a volte possa essere
un male necessario possa liberare una
libia da un gheddafi in afghanistan le
talebani possa difendervi dal cai dense
in guerra si muore basta mi sono
laureata in diritto internazionale il
diritto internazionale si basa tutto
sulla distinzione tra civili e
combattenti su questa idea della guerra
come uno scontro tra eserciti mi hanno
insegnato che in guerra più o meno si
sta di qui o di lì che cioè che c'è una
linea del fronte che civili sono il
danno collaterale invece il danno
collaterale sono i soldati l'obiettivo
siamo noi il fronte non è una linea in
aria e l'area della battaglia chi c'è
c'è
perché quello in cui vivo e anche un
deserto di regole e norme si colpisce
tutto e tutto 12 10 santa volte neanche
ed è un deserto di logica non c'è una
razionalità cena a casa
israele bombarda bombarda bombarda notte
e giorno e pensi mi rifugio in un refuso
dell'onu poi pensi o forse no forse
forse israele dimostra che è capace di
bombardare anche un rifugio dell'oro
pensi tre brand pensi forse è meglio una
casa bassa una casa a un piano due
altrimenti se viene centrata ti crolla
in testa un palazzo intero quei pensi
invece forse no forse meglio una casa
alta altrimenti ti crolla addosso anche
con una cannonata anche con una granata
non c'è logica non c'è salvezza perché
il mio tanto e anche è anche un deserto
di responsabilità mori ecocity andata
nessuno pagherà nessuno in guerra amore
e basta e morì anche male eppure eppure
a febbraio al primo cessate il fuoco
mediato dalle nazioni unite
la prima ora del primo giorno del primo
se state il fuoco i siriani di sirene da
tempo sono tornati in piazza magri
malconce stremati decimati
ma come prima cosa dopo cinque anni e
500 mila morti siriani sono tornati in
piazza
l'unica differenza è che ora sono sia
contro la stanza contro al qaeda cinque
anni e 500 mila morti è cambiato tutto
abbiamo abbiamo perso tutto oppure al
fondo sto ancora raccontando la stessa
storia anche anche se adesso c'è una
guerra intorno ma sto ancora raccontando
una battaglia per la libertà e la
dignità non è cambiato niente perché per
uno che spara in sia per uno che
bombarda che fa che fa un deserto altre
100 lasciano deserto tra al qaeda sa di
siriani hanno scelto hanno scelto di
andare via i profughi che sbarcano sulle
nostre coste in fuga dalle mille serie
del mondo in fuga da guerre povertà
persecuzione non sono disperati al
contrario sono quelli quelli che non si
sono arresi non sono i più fragili sono
i più forti sono quelli quelli che
nessuno fermerà nessun'arma nessuna
frontiera perché hanno un sogno perché
sembrano le vittime sembrano quelli che
subiscono alla deriva in balia del mare
degli eventi e invece sono quelli
stanchi di subire all'energia hanno
carattere hanno determinato
nessuna intenzione di accomodarsi nel
destino vogliono una vita diversa voglio
una vita migliore sono quelli che
davanti al deserto dicono non ci sto
il deserto il deserto per me qui si
raccontavano di mubarak in piazza tahrir
questi ragazzi brillanti esclusiva tutto
una laurea e un dottorato un inglese
perfetto e nessun lavoro erano camerieri
tassisti meccanici venditori ambulanti
con il loro dottorato in astrofisica
friggere patatine per strada mi
raccontavano non tanto la disoccupazione
quanto la disuguaglianza si raccontavano
la corruzione il nepotismo il
clientelismo il talento che conta zero
conta solo la famiglia da cui vieni gli
amici che hai sembrava sembrava
raccontassero l'italia
a parte la repressione della polizia che
può in italia bisognerebbe chiedere non
a noi ma gli immigrati agli stefano
cucchi e federico aldovrandi ma a parte
questo da un punto di vista economico e
sociale era la stessa cosa
non abbiamo fallito solo perché non
abbiamo mai avuto il coraggio di
provarci
i contrasti iraq sono una corrispondente
di guerra eppure dei tanti paesi di cui
ho scritto il più difficile è stato la
grecia atene
qui dietro all'alba al porto al pireo
attraccava un traghetto proveniente
dalle isole
i siriani e iracheni gli afghani
andavano rapidi verso la metropolitana
verso il centro per ripartire subito per
il nord della germania per la svezia
dopo dopo un paio d'ore nelle strade
intorno per terra il sole ancora
addormentati sud e cartone non
rimanevano che loro i greci magri
malconci con questa pelle logora era
simulavano spiccioli rivendendo tutto
quello che trovavano in soffitta vecchie
radio vecchi telefoni vecchi vestiti
scarpe sfondate un phon una pagaia un
trapano una boccetta di profumo
consumata a metà qui dietro al pireo a
mezzogiorno erano tutti in fila davanti
davanti alla chiesa davanti alla mensa
tutti tutti identici attenti la senza
parlare con lo sguardo basso con le all
star e lo zanet uisp ha come il tuo
rosso sera
c'era questo signore distinto che
sembrava un professore universitario con
l'abito grigio la la cartella di pelle
una ragazzina
la ragazzina che aveva avuto non più di
14 anni con gli occhiali i capelli neri
un libro sotto il braccio l'aria aveva
l'aria di una passata di lì all'uscita
da scuola passata a mendicare la sua
vaschetta di riso e pollo e un pezzo di
pane qui dietro e non è come in guerra
perché in guerra pensi che sono un altro
e tutto temporanea un certo punto tutto
finisse anche la siria ma in grecia no
grecia capisci che strutturale che oggi
semplicemente non c'è spazio per tutti
qualcuno resta fuori qualcuno resta
presto in fila non sono i serbi e croati
sunniti e gli sciiti non c'è nessuna
pace da negoziare ti dicono e la crisi
del capitalismo cosa fai con la crisi
del capitalismo da dove inizi e non è la
grecia e la mia generazione la
generazione ap dicono sempre non si sono
risorse per un reportage da musulin
italia ti pagano 120 euro per
un'inchiesta su regioni ecco l'italia
che dice siamo fieri di giulio regioni
siamo fieri di voi in italia in cui
un'inchiesta sul tuo micidio devi pagare
sul suo omicidio di pagare di tasca tua
perché per un giornale giulia regioni
vale 120 euro
ti dicono ci dispiace ma è la
globalizzazione la transizione al
digitale la cina è una cosa complicata
poi direttore generale della rai
guadagna 650mila euro l'anno no non è
una cosa complicata
eppure nessuno parla nessuno dice non ci
sto
ognuno cerca la salvezza individuale
oggi l'ottanta per cento delle notizie
80 per cento di tutto quello che leggete
guardate sui giornali su internet in
televisione per radio 80 per cento
arriva da freelance come senza mezzo
diritto
ho detto non raccontano sul per 120 euro
non mi ci ripaga ma anche il biglietto
erio subito ha detto di sì un altro
convinto che prima o poi liberazione in
redazione no si libererà un posto uno
solo invece le 10 del passato proprio
poi no un posto si libererà e quindi uno
dice di sì sì a tutto per stare lì
pronto
quel giorno invece lavoriamo tutti
sottocosto un anno grande tre anni fino
al giorno in cui in banca finiamo in
rosso e veniamo sostituiti questo
giornalismo oggi questa è la mia
generazione
questo è il deserto in cui viviamo ma
nessuno dice non ci sto
e la cosa più insensata e che non è che
in questi anni abbiamo redistribuito la
ricchezza non è che siamo diventati più
poveri perché altri potessero essere
meno poveri per fabbricare i nostri
iphone
assange è 50 mila cinesi lavorano dodici
ore al giorno con la sana di stanchezza
sulle linee di montaggio dormono nei
magazzini e così in bangladesh così in
brasile in india romania così ovunque in
cambio della nostra ricchezza abbiamo
creato non ricchezza ma povertà e guerra
in libia metà dei giallisti viene dalla
tunisia
partono come un tempo partivano per
lampedusa per l'italia per l'europa in
cerca di lavoro non vogliono il
califfato vogliono lo stipendio perché
sono alla fame
a kasserine una città che non a caso ha
il più alto tasso sia di già visti sia
di disoccupati un mese fa si è avuto il
tentato suicidio di massa di laureati
ragazzi laureati e disperati l'economia
in tunisia si basa sul turismo è un
turismo ha dominato dagli operatori
stranieri da questi operatori low cost
che offrono una settimana tra centro e
quando pagate 300 euro volo incluso ogni
tanto così quando qualcuno esplode nel
vostro ristorante chiedetevi quanto
viene pagato il vostro cameriere
chiedetevi che vita fa il vostro
cameriere se vogliamo fermare i
jihadisti in libia non ha senso
bombardare la libia non dobbiamo
intervenire in libia dobbiamo
intervenire in tunisia 62 miliardari
oggi possiedono 62 la stessa ricchezza
della metà della popolazione del pianeta
l'un per cento più ricco del mondo oggi
è più ricco di tutti gli altri di tutti
noi insieme e noi siamo al suo servizio
siamo la sua fanteria
mi è difficile essere qui stasera mi è
difficile parlare sono sono giorni che
non dormo aleppo e sotto assedio sta sta
per cadere si vive
dopo cinque anni sta per cadere si vive
di erbe le erbe radici acqua piovana una
media di un bombardamento ogni due
minuti ognuna di queste ted
sono diciotto minuti ogni 39 morti sono
morti 9 mentre mi avete ascoltato questa
questi aleppo adesso però
però quel deserto quelle quelle macerie
io ho visto quelle strade sgretolarsi
una una a quelle case crollare una una
in tutte le guerre che ho visto non ho
mai visto sunniti e sciiti cristiani e
musulmani o di ancestrali ho visto ho
visto solo uomini solo singoli uomini
con le loro azioni e le loro decisioni
le loro scelte una una una dopo l'altra
singole crudeltà singole ottusità
singolo e paure le azioni e le reazioni
e le reazioni alle reazioni le guerre in
cui vivono sono guerre di massimi
sistemi mai sono piuttosto guerre di
piccole miserie guerre che accadono non
perché siano inevitabili inarrestabile
espressione delle forze profonde della
storia degli istinti più oscuri
dell'animo umano no accadono perché
vengono lasciate a cadere dalle piccole
complicità dalle piccole vigliaccherie
i piccoli silenzi le grandi in
differenze mi chiedono spesso ma qual è
la soluzione soluzione viene da solver e
risolvere da qui anche risolversi
decidersi per risolvere bisogna
scegliere scegliere da che parte stare
ogni volta che non dici non ci sto ogni
volta che ti adegui di uniformi ogni
volta che non fai un eccezione a pechino
regole invece che il buon senso e non
perché sia più giusto così ma perché è
più comodo così ogni volta che non fai
niente con il pretesto che tanto non
sarebbe abbastanza ogni volta che mentre
aspetti che sia trovata una soluzione
la soluzione globale la soluzione
definitiva intanto nel tuo piccolo
continui a contribuire al problema ogni
volta che sai tutto il giorno a spalla a
spalla con un cecchino e quello sempre
ti tira fuori dalla tasca la foto di un
figlio di un fratello ucciso e ti dice
non vorrei mai essere qui sono contro la
violenza
combatto perché nessuno si è più
costretto a combattere ti dice sempre
perché nessuno aveva più quello che ho
vissuto io abbatte il primo che passa un
figlio un fratello
il cui padre cui fratello il giorno dopo
starà lì dall'altra parte del fronte con
una foto in tasca e un fucile in mano
abbatte il primo che passa si accende
una sigaretta e ti dice io sono contro
la violenza ma tu ti dice tu vedi
un'altra soluzione forse
sì certo che sì la soluzione sei tu
[Musica]